in this video we'll talk about
chemokines chemokines are small chemo
attractant molecules which can recruit
cells into within or outside the tissue
for the sake of argument let's say this
is a site of infection where you can
find many bacteria and these pathogenic
bacteria are engulfed by these dendritic
cells which are phagocytes this
dendritic cell would eventually secrete
chemokines shown here in black and these
chemokines would further attract other
immune cells for example more
neutrophils or even more dendritic
cellular macrophages into the site of
infection and that would be like an
alarming signal or a backup call
so how does these additional immune
cells like neutrophils like macrophages
can potentially find the site of
infection
so here is the dendritic cell which has
secreted the chemokines generally
speaking these neutrophils or other
immune cells kind of sense the chemokine
gradient and just by sensing the
chemokine gradient they can potentially
locate the site of infection
but at a molecular level how chemokine
signaling Works in order to understand
let's zoom into the new neutrophil and
try to understand how chemokine
signaling can work
so the chemokine signaling starts when
chemokine binds to the chemokine
receptor which is a g-protein-coupled
receptor
so ligand binding lead to activation of
trimeric G protein
and it can start different Cascades of
signal in one hand it can activate
phospholipas C
and ultimately leads to an activation of
NF Kappa beta and translocation of NF
Kappa beta into the nucleus this
transcription Factor can transcribe many
genes including genes of inflammatory
cytokines and many other chemo
attractant factors
also
the G protein couple signaling can
activate rho gtpases rho gtps's are
implicated in cell movement so obviously
cell migration and cytoskeletal
rearrangement can be triggered by row
activation
now G protein coupled receptor signaling
and chemokin receptor can potentially
crosstalk between many signals such as
Jack stat signal and Pi 38kt signal and
that leads to cell survival
it has been also shown that there is an
interaction with map kinase pathway and
chemokine receptor which leads to an
activation of Ras and eventually make
Arc and the whole map kindness Cascade
this leads to Arc translocation into the
nucleus and thereby activating signals
which would lead to gene expression and
these category of genes Falls onto cell
growth proliferation and cell survival
ultimately few things are happening due
to chemical and signaling cell movement
cell survival proliferation and survival
of these cells
now let us try to put things in context
now let's see how chemokine signaling is
important for T cells
after its stringent training in the
thymus T cells become naive the naive T
cells
leave to the lymph node now the naive T
cells has chemokine receptors like DC
like cxcr4
ccr7
Etc all these chemokine receptors and
corresponding signals allow them to be
translocated into the nearby lymph node
where they can interact with further
antigen presenting cells like dendritic
cells
now different subtypes of T cells has
different kind of chemokine receptors so
in this case hemokin receptor also work
like a signature to identify different
cell types
for example after interaction with the
dendritic cell in the lymph node the T
cell would ultimately become let's say
th1 cell or th2 subpopulation based on
the polarizing cytokine or the
polarizing interleukin it would interact
with
now both these two different cell types
has different kind of chemokine
receptors on their surface
th1 subtype has cxcr3 cxcr1 cxcr2 and
cxcr5
whereas the th2 subtypes has ccr3 ccr4
ccr2 subtypes
so CCR stands for chemokine receptors
and CCL stands for chemokine ligands let
us take another example let's say this
is the site of infection where there are
a lot of bacterial Innovation so first
the dendritic cell reach there engulf
pathogens and secrete interleukin 8 or
cxcl8 this was the first discovered
chemokine
so this particular chemokine would be
sensed by neutrophils basophils and
immature dendritic cells which are in
the circulation
this particular signaling helps in
extravasation of these lymphocytes into
the tissue space and they get recruited
into the infection site further the
dendritic cell secretes cxcl 12 and 14
which help to mobilize more and more
dendritic cell into the site of
infection and all of these events lead
to a inflammation in that particular
region of infection
in context of tumor and cancer biology
chemokine signaling is super important
it turns out there are several
chemokines secreted by the tumor cells
attracts many immune cells into the
tumor region for example cxcl12
9 and 10 attracts cytotoxic T cells and
natural killer cells
note that natural killer cells and
cytotoxic T cells has different type of
chemokine receptors on their surface
there are other chemokines such as
ccl22 and ccl17 that attracts tea
regulatory cell
there are chemokines like cxcl5 cxcl12
which attracts neutrophils and ccl4 CCL
20 attracts dendritic cell so a complex
chemokine signaling is happening in the
tumor microenvironment which help to
modulate the immune responses around the
tumors
now recent findings has found that
chemokine signaling and dysregulation of
chemokine signaling is associated with
many disease including lung cancer brain
cancer breast cancer pancreatic tumors
renal carcinoma and many other cancers
if you want to get a better Outlook of
this particular topic
take a look at the review which is
pinned in the description I hope this
video gives you an idea about chemokine
and chemokine signaling for more notes
and flashcards follow us on Instagram
and Facebook links are in the
description you can support our Channel
using super thanks you can pay via paytm
PayPal or UPI you can follow us on
various social media all links are
pinned in the description see you in
next video
thank you